Design matters and it matters for governments. Likecompanies, countries spend a lot of time and money
on branding themselves so that they cancommunicate clearly to their citizens
and also so that they can set themselves apartfrom others.
Now, when talking about how things look, it's always important to understand that taste anddesign is subjective,
with the exception of my own which is unparalleled in its sophistication.
Butif we establish what goals governments are trying to reach with their design,
it becomes a loteasier to determine objectively what a good or bad design decision is
And there is one country
in particular
— assuming you think good government design is functional and minimalist design —
thatstands out on top.
And that's the Netherlands.
If good government design is that which brandsa nation as strong to the rest of the world,
a country that is probably more fitting is France.
Itslogo includes the country's most important symbols: the red, white and blue,
with the blue being since
recently changed back to its traditional color,
and it also includes France's
most important national icon.
The french design goes a step further though
by also communicating their ground values more explicitly
than what may be typical even
when compared with stereotypically louder nations.
"E pluribus unum. Out of many, one."
Alternatively, if good government design means that it shows
off your unique and immediately recognizableassets,
the Netherlands also isn't first in line.
It's not that tulips aren't great in all or thatthe Dutch sky isn't beautiful
but a country like Estonia, which is known as one of the first that
completely digitized its own government,
sometimes does a better job looking like an e-commercecompany than an actual government.
Another example of a country that is very effective at marketing
its own personal brand
would be Sweden, which has seemingly delegated all of its branding to private
industry.
Also, if good government design is defined bystrictly upholding certain rules and standards
almost to the point of insanity, to everyone'samazement and surprise
the Germans and theSwiss are probably the leaders.
What makes Dutch government design good is its functionality
and simplicity
that comes close to but definitely is not: boring.
It stays uniform while also
giving room for each individual ministry
and it immediately communicates to the Dutch peoplethat something is part of the Dutch state.
It does this while also remaining very flat and simple, which also immediately reminds you of the country.
In the typical Dutch obsessionwith being as normal as possible
even the national serif font looks like
it's trying its hardest not to be a serif.
In 2007, Dutch Prime Minister Balkenende
whowas always known for his especially creative unique and eccentric personality
madethe surprising decision to centralize government design
and get rid of the hundreds of
individually unique government associated logos
in order to make a more, quiteliterally, monolithic block
At the time this wasn't typical as there were only afew countries
that had actively tried tocentralize their branding schemes
And as we canexpect from humanity and particularly the Dutch, a lot of people were critical.
You had of coursethe natural debate on whether the government was spending too much money
and the Dutch military, which as you know, has always been considered the Netherlands strongest asset
and really uniquecharacteristic on the world stage,
was so opposed that the government conceded to give each military
branch their own special logo.
One of the main criticisms, however, which is what gets to the
heart of why the design is actually pretty good,
is that the Dutch government design is just toobland.
But this is the wrong way to look at it.
It is not a new thing to question that what you maygain in function will be lost in individuality.
It's an endless discussion and there are plentyof examples of where companies have given up creative expression for almost unnecessarysimplicity.
But some could say that governments should be judged by different standards.
For many people, not including those who waste their incredibly valuable time consumingpolitical content online,
governments can be considered to be doing their best job whenits citizens aren't thinking much about it.
Take emergency services: this is one of the areaswhere government probably does want to make sure
it's visible and clearly demarcated in dailylife.
The solution for them are funky stripes, which give the impression that there are morevisible emergency services
without coming off as intimidating or relying on the cheap use of
neon,
which many other European police vehicles do.
Unfortunately, there are still plenty of Dutchpeople who don't appreciate the design of Dutch
emergency services like I do.
But there are plentyof other examples of good Dutch government design.
For example: letters.
Each comes off assubtle enough except for the dark blue which is immediately associated with the Dutch taxauthorities
also conveniently the only important letter you actually need to open.
And thereare some designs that are even more subtle.
If i show you this logo and try to imaginethat you've never seen it before in your life
what does it tell you?
Nothing. But of course
most Europeans know immediately that it signals the Deutsche Bahn
which is Germany's national
rail service.
And the same is true for the TGV.
It doesn't immediately tell you at face valuethat it's France's high-speed rail service
but what if I show you this logo:
It's subtle, sure, but you could also easily imagine yourself making the connection
between this and the Netherlands'
national rail company.
The NS logo is also not so obvious to the point that it's explicit
likethe Czech Republic's national rail company.
All of this is not to say that Dutch design isperfect.
No, there are plenty of things that I, with my childish desire to come off as intelligent andworldly as possible,
can't even really act like I understand either.
For example: PostNL
It is whatit is. Or better yet, the recently upgraded, national parliament,
which looks more like an IKEA-filled
dentist waiting room along with a bunch of rocks glued onto the wall.
And there are plenty of
other governments that are also pretty functional.
Where each ministry in the Netherlands cantechnically choose their own department's color
even though that color won't be explicitlyacknowledged as theirs,
the UK does have uniquely color-coded ministries,
which is much more slick
in my unquestionable and authoritative opinion.
Where the Germans may have phenomenaland groundbreaking industrial design
the Swiss placement in grids and the Italian'sdesign that makes you feel incredibly inferior
the Dutch navigate a very fine line betweenfun, simple and sober.
And for a government that probably doesn't want to come off as anything
more than normal,
that's probably perfectly okay.
"No!"